what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here john how are you
i'm so good andrew i'm doing well all
right guys well we got ourselves an
official trailer for the disney plus
show tales
of the jedi
and it looks like uh clone wars
animation style so let's get into it and
see what's going on also you know use
the force to leave a like that would be
very much appreciated
everywhere there is life
but
you must face
death
honor it
do not fear it
baby soccer
jedi
ahsoka is jedi
the best way i can protect you
is to teach you how to protect yourself
i'm so cool i want to bring peace
dooku as a jedi sweet
why gone it is the only way you will
truly have victory why you better one
wow dang he doesn't look like he's cool
he does look like a young
again
oh so excited to see them again
stand down
[Music]
i've been warning them about the coming
darkness
let's
hope pays off
mr rex
and who might you be
[Applause]
oh awesome
yeah that looks exciting
yeah it looks really exciting
that's cool man i like what the star
wars have been doing with their
animation department of you know you had
visions which i thought i mean i think
we both liked it quite a bit i didn't
feel like i got enough traction but this
obviously i feel like we get way more
traction considering the fact that these
this is the like the clone war style i
mean you're you're bringing back ahsoka
and anakin and looking at the early days
of them training together i mean i think
the most exciting part though is you get
to see dooku as a jedi for the first
time
that's like a long overdue story that
yeah you'd think that by now we would
have seen it and it's just like wow
watch us oh damn
we've never seen that that's pretty
crazy so yeah i think there's a lot to
look forward to here and it does feel
like still sprawling and and it feels uh
well intimate you know it's not the word
i thought i'd be associating with this
yeah so yeah but uh john yeah no this
this definitely looked exciting i mean
as somebody who has you know is been
sort of steeping into the clone wars
universe and then looking at all the
different live-action things this is
kind of like a cool convergence point
for me because the clone wars was like a
very formidable prospect to me at the
outset and this takes that but it also
combines it with some very familiar and
you know iconic characters from the live
action stuff as well that's like
directly accessible to that so you have
like the tutelage of qui-gon jinn and
things like that and i would love to see
yeah that history along with the
expansion on that beloved back and forth
between ahsoka and anakin and just any
kind of peripheral details i feel like
you free yourself up in a way to tell
interesting uh you know more complex
perhaps stories when you're in sort of a
slightly anthological scenario so uh
yeah i mean i loved the blend of tones
that we're looking at here you know like
it looks appropriately intense and fun
but there's also some stuff that looks a
little more somber and cinematic and a
little more akin to the movie side as
well as the clone wars aspects so yeah
this looks super cool ginger ever since
may 2002 when i saw everyone's favorite
film attack at the clones in theaters
uh there was a line in that movie which
really got me like really just playing
things in my mind like i want to see
that story was when count dooku said to
obi-wan kenobi when he was in that that
holding chamber he said
that he was qui-gon jinn's master i was
like man i've always wanted and i'd love
to see a story where we get to see that
him training qui-gon or at least some
flashbacks something so when i heard the
idea of this i was like wow this has me
intrigued but actually like seeing it
now in trailer form like man this is so
cool just seeing that hilt and that
lightsaber i'm like that's awesome
because obviously that's he had the red
lightsaber but yeah i know this looks
really cool and i like how they really
get that look down of uh
of uh qui-gon jin it looks like a really
young liam neeson but i'm really
intrigued that but i think the thing
that was really uh interesting to me as
well was just seeing dooku like
drawing like he's always had a little
bit of a dark side in him even when he
was uh a jedi like you had to see uh
samuel jackson's uh mace windu you had
to see
you had to see mace windu tell him like
dooku stop and i just thought that was
like okay look he's always had a little
dark side in him he's always on that
edge of you know like
struggling between that line of good and
evil so i'm really looking forward to
this and yeah i really want to see too
if i'm not sure if they're gonna have
time to show like i'm not sure like how
they're gonna do the tales of time in
this but i'm really curious to see i
want to see qui-gon train obi-wan kenobi
as well i want to see get get some
glimpses of that because i've always
been intrigued with that because we only
got the tail end of that when we saw the
phantom menace in 99 so i'm really
intrigued at the thought of the notion
of seeing that as well qui-gon and uh
dooku jeez we're reminded right now
so many names in the star wars so many
names right dooku and qui-gon i'm really
intrigued at that but i also want to see
obi-wan kenobi and qui-gon as well i'm
really intrigued with the notion of that
and ahsoka uh sokatano and uh obi and
anakin skywalker yeah so many names one
might do
so many
but anakin and
ahsoka i'm really i love that
relationship too and i'm so glad they
got ashley eckstein back she is she just
embodies the voice of
a soccer tone ahsoka tona and uh
i'm on it right now i'm on it guys
she
she really embodies the voice of the
character and as much as i love rosario
dawson in the live-action form uh ashley
eckstein is is this character to me and
i'm really i'm really really interested
to see her back as well but also seeing
that relationship just expand more
between her and anakin because i love
that relationship it's a really
endearing relationship for me yeah i
mean in the final season of clone wars
2. by the way i don't want to cut up
anything you said i thought that was
it's got to stay raw
it's
all the correct names was beautiful
stumbling is the best best the best
discussions like running down a flight
of stairs when you're leaning too far
forward but you can't stop remember
everything correctly andrew do it dude
um no i think i think ahsoka and uh
anakin we because of the final season
and what they had to tell in that final
season when the show got uh resurrected
for disney plus
we didn't really get much of them
together just because of the specific
story they had to tell and i and i think
that with getting a a taste of again of
the beginnings with them
is delightful all right tails the jedi
this is the first video we shot today
and this is our warm-up their warm-up
let's see if this goes live i like the
trailer that was awesome i thought it
was good
all right guys
t23 we're killing it